What’s the worst thing that’s happened to you today?
Well, I lost my luggage.
That explains the shirt.
I made my hotel reservation 11 and a half months ago.
They got cancelled last month,
and I only got a place today for two nights.
Hey, I’m Traci in San Diego outside the Team Coco house.
And today, State Farm and Team Coco have paired up
to turn a few lucky fans day around.
Are you a big Conan O’Brien fan?
Yes.
Can you do an impression of Conan?
Oh, yeah, totally.
Yes! I mean, are you Conan O’Brien?
Um, I don’t think I’m tall enough.
I see the resemblance.
What’s the worst thing that’s happened today?
Oh, well, it’s always like the lines,
and everything like that.
And people cutting.
I mean, that’s horrible.
Were you behind anybody that was
just, like, heinous?
Sometimes people are smelly because it’s hot.
People do kinda smell, I’ve realized that throughout the day.
You’ve been banking on something for 11 months
and then it fell through today?!
Yes. But I’m here now, it’s okay.
You know who else is here?
State Farm is here to help life go right.
Oh, thank you!
You gonna collect a lot of those
tiny, little baby hats?
Yes!
Do you feel like your day is about to turn around?
Um, I’m hoping so.
I have one more little gift for you.
I have for you
two tickets to a live taping of Conan O’Brien, tonight!
Oh my goodness. Oh my god!
They’re so hard to get.
I’m going to CONAN!
Thank you State Farm for turning my day around!
You gotta go, left, right…yeah, that’s feeling good.
I’m nailing this.